ومن اعتصام لاهالي الاسرى امام مقر وزاره
الدفاع في تل ابيب تنضم الينا الان
مراسلتنا نجوان سمري نجوان ضعنا في صوره
ما يجري حولك
الان نعم ليلى هذا الاعتصام متواصل طيله
النهار هنا قباله مقر وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه ل عشرات من ذوي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه جزء منهم موجود
في
منطقه ما باتت تعرف
في ميدان المحتجزين او ميدان الرهائن في
تل ابيب لكن الجزء الاخر نقلوا هذا
الاعتصام منذ ايام الى هذا الموقع
تحديدا بعد يوم الجمعه عندما تم الاعلان
عن مقتل
الاسرى الاسرائيليين
بنيران جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في غزه
حيث صعد هذا الحراك من احتجاجاته الشعبيه
للمطالبه لمطالبه الحكومه ومجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي فعل كل شيء من اجل الافراج عن
الاسرى من
غزه قبل قليل يعني سمعنا من العائلات
تحديدا
التي ظهر
ظهر منها الاسماء من ممن يتواجدون في غزه
عفوا الفيديو الذي نشرته
القسام يعني سمعنا منهم بانهم يشعرون
بالفرح لانهم راوا
بان الاباء والاجداد منهم على قيد الحياه
لكن ايضا عائلات اخرى عبرت عن غضبها بان
الحكومه مازالت تبقيهم في ذلك
الموقع اعلنت بانها ستصعد من حراكها اذا
ان يتم الافراج عنهم جميعا لكن من جهه
اخرى ايضا تحدثت وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه
هذه الليله عن ان هناك بالفعل تقدم في
امكانيه الوصول الى صفقه تبادل عبر
الوسطاء في المباحثات الجاريه على عده
اطراف
لكنها
ان اسرائ مترده ح اتمام صفقه شامله تشمل
كل الاسر ام فقط جزء ضم ما يعرف بصفقه
انسانيه لفئات محدده فقط
من وهذا ربما مازال قيد المباحثات في
اسرائيل ومع الوسطاء ولكن ايضا هناك يبدو
بان اسرائيل بدات تدرس ايضا ان تقوم
بالافراج عن اسرى يعتبروا في اسرائيل او
ادينوا في محاكم الاحتلال بانهم قتلوا
اسرائيليين ممن يعرفون بذوي المحكيات
العاليه هذا جديد هذا نوع من التراجع من
قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه عما اعلنته في
المره السابقه عندما كانت هناك صفقه
تبادل قبل قبل عده اسابيع تم بموجبها
الافراج عن فئه الاطفال والنساء نرى هنا
هذه اللافته
ل ملاح الجو الاسرائيلي رونا راد الذي فقد
في لبنان عام
1986 بعد تحطم مروحيته و وكتب هنا لا تبق
تبقو نحن ايضا لوحدنا بمعنى طله الوقت
هناك مطالبات من قبل اهالي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين والعائلات لانهم لا
يريدون 129 رون اراد اخر بخصوص الاسرى في
غزه ومن الواضح ان هذا الحراك سيتم تصعيده
في الايام القريبه المقبله هذا اليوم
اعلنت ايضا هيئه العائلات بانها
س
عفوا اعلنت هذه العائلات بانها بانها جزء
من عائلات خطن الحرب على غزه قد تم قد
شاركتهم هذا الاحتجاج اليوم وانضمت الى
هذا الاحتجاج وهذا عمليا يعارض تماما ما
قاله بنيامين نتنياهو يوم امس في جلسه
الحكومه الذي قال بانه عائلات الجنود
القتلى طالبوه ان يوقف هذه الحرب وعدم
التوقف في منتصف الطريق والمواصله الى حين
مواصله الحرب وتحقيق اهدافها في غزه
شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سمري